hello and welcome to our
daily meeting for the press online and
live on obs we are
today Monday February 1st
yesterday in the afternoon the president of
the commission to the strong man of the nc
meeting by videoconference with  the CEOs
of the pharmaceutical companies with
whom the commission negotiated the
advance purchase contracts in the case
of our vaccine strategy the subject
of this meeting was the preparation of the
work of the european union and the
european commission in particular
on defense  as the
president announced in her
state of the union
speech on pardon in her davos speech the
commission wants to set up a
health emergency response authority
that will be in charge
of improving the european response
private industry will play a key
role in this mission but also,
of course, public institutions
and European institutions
the participants have  also discussed
practical proposals to improve the
development, manufacture
and approval of vaccines against the copy
of 19 and these variants the president
was accompanied by the commissioners
thierry breton and stella kyriakides s of
this special adviser peter piotte is
there the meeting also benefited
the experience of mr moncef slaoui
who led the world speed operation in
the united states as well as our
executive director of the european
medicine agency mrs nicole cooke who
also gave the agency's vision on
priority subjects in the field
from bio defense I would now like to
give the floor to stéphane who has an
announcement on the summit for
vaccination this afternoon
oh god of thunder commission what they
have for you participating vis à vis
holdings limited jankovits night is big
thing  hendrix nations in ghana
by jove turning angela merkel of your
discs do battle in the text where
nineteen vaccine cohabit  e world youth
bordeaux vaccine manufacture this monday
by a kind of book a honda precedes
purchase agreement
stéphanie would not have any blur all
vivienne at the end of 2008
hello to the questions in relation to the
priorities or not if you hear me
it's just on my part I say  I said as a
question it's in relation to small air
always on corner good in any case
it's emmanuel macron he said Saturday
that for the new negotiations on
the nuclear power
it is also necessary that by participating the opinions
son replied the reacted to  this question
he said no there will be more
negotiations and i'm playing it for you
what is the position of mr morel and
then peter k
so to get married it's a the role
of a high representative like a
coordinator of  a nuclear treaty
currently nuclear it is not
commented on the rumor that individual of the
participants of enjoy if so but in
fact it makes every effort to
ensure that the the nuclear hakama of
books the result which is respected  by
all the participants that all the
compliments all the obligations are
respected by the by the countries one
participant thank you peter
we will therefore continue on the
external relations chapter I will
ask you to keep your hand
raised for the moment only if it is a
external affairs question we
will come back to the other
subjects later
so prison and which would take some
hot corners and in actions relaxnews I
see that jean
quatremer has a question on
foreign zekri purchases so you hear me I will
try that I will wait for you that  'they are
all aspects are strange beings
yes concerning the export of
vaccines no sorry jean that will be for
later it's not a question of
external relations it's a question
finally we deal with all these questions with
regard to the  health chapter that ovide
and c have made the questions
relating to the portfolio of pîtres first
and we will come back to you of course
immediately after  After their creation, we
must quickly get into action Wilkins of Mozilla, a
vocation to train the weather at the two
committees concerned and for two
rounds on the dessert and this problem
five nuclear museums do you do you is
committed anything to fight for your
eyes of the witch and where  is used in
establishing contact raising hope you're
winning team soho by peter and nabila
another collector explained peter
this ad a portfolio to nabila this
portfolio a double contact
the arrival of m my son
and it's a shame whether he or not de
redemption lawsuit cutter asked to
suspend this photo is the fact of an
unexpected manner mrs reding juridico mrna
barney stinson continue to sulk
institute wri force against part one
has programs authorized to nine
dead bodies of dieter finding offering a
dividend in accordance with a  fashion as
stylist anna valley of course we are in
time
faurecia meeting and they will continue
in action of 16 christian yes hello I
stay  I will be on russia in fact I
would like to know if you have the
feeling yesterday in the declaration of the
bourg she that he represented
the unanimity of the member states
when I looked at the
positions taken by different member states
I saw that many
from eastern and northern european countries condemned the repression
of demonstrations while
mr bourrel chose a much weaker term
which is deplored with the support
of france
in a fairly assertive way do
you have the  feeling that by
choosing words and this is important diplomacy
you have made a gesture in favor of a
certain type of member state and against
a certain number of other member states
so that is my first
question because  that the others you
answered thank you thank you christiane it's not
for me to make the interpretation on the
choice of words the expression of the countries
of an individual member country member countries
the representative indicated saint
saëns on Monday and published in the  tweet I
think it's very consistent with the message
of the last foreign affairs council
when we also discussed an
event in russia there was no part of
the european union but the things that
suit us in lyon 1-0  now in
russia are not acceptable
the example of the medicine treatments
before nice is not acceptable because
it is one thing which who does not forget
it was by the european union based
several main for example there  there is
still the situation as we
do not have the answers on the
questions on the assassinations have on
the incidence to sign but it is navalni
with a
chemical demand so we have
discussions in the european union the
discussion continues there the
foreign affairs council was an example of the
cons of this high
level
discussion but the discussion between the
member countries continues I don't think
it was a sign
if you then had to choose
very harsh words at the very  weak
the thing which is very which is more
important it is the position and repaints
that this development are not
acceptable the treatment of medicine
before going there according to who supports
it it is not acceptable
and it is a reason also by  a relative
what is a travel representative to
moscow to discuss with our
russian partners
is there a very clear and very
strong message from the european union it is not the
private message of messi bruce and a
message on behalf of the countries  Europeans who
have discussed these topics and who say
cost these topics regularly
thank you I was in now at 1 a.m.
[Applause]
hello I want to come back to the iron and
I will rephrase the first
criticism was made so is that in other
words the  european women's union and in
favor of a renegotiation of
the nuclear agreement with iran
is what the european union is in
favor of alain laporte the incorporation
of other regional actors including the framework
of the site of these  possible negotiations
thank you thank you for the deletion repeated
that the european currency is a
coordinator of a treaty that exist
they decision on change to the
treaty are not for the
european union not to do it is a decision
of the participants
of these  treated decently is an
appropriate form at the appropriate level for
all discussions on the future on the
content on the respect jessy pi this is
where a joint commission of the jaycees
would have had we can discuss for the
things that are the participants can
find agreement at the  unity but
it's not for the european union
gave proposals on the changes
of this reduction is due in the eyes of
certain treaties because our role
is to ensure the coordination of the
participating countries there if I give the floor to
nicolas
nicolas  don't see you yes hello I have
two or three little questions I'm going to
go very quickly because I think there
are a lot of people in Russia I
wanted to be  e sure that the requests of the
delegations of the european union the
member states of the delegation of
the european union in moscow to
meet the opponents
so i wanted to know if there was a
step in this direction that was made to
wait
before the  visit by josé beaurain from
moscow on burma I wanted to know
apart from the condemnation of the coup d'
etat do you undertake to
quickly reinstate the sanctions which are affecting
we are going to take the sanctions which are affecting
moment is lost nantes has lost but you
are  question are we going to
restore the sanctions which hit the
Burmese regime which hits Burma
so there were sanctions which
hit Burma so I wanted to
know if it is established and opposite
the mention of the European Union I
want  know if the problem and is about
to be solved and to
avoid intervening later I just wanted
to add a little word in the general
perhaps for more of the general
aspect  al du val d'oise researcher I
think it would be quite a lesson on
art fauna unfortunately your connection to be
cut we will answer
you that's what will prevent me from misunderstanding
ok ok not what I understood c  is the
first question on russia I
can't confirm with plowing and more
in detail on the nature of our contacts
with the marni sponsorship team so
as I say we try we are in
contact with the medical team before
him we try of course
it's true that it will be possible to
have a meeting but there are no
more details that I can share
now we gonna be the end of what in
miyama yes hello can you
hear me  yes go go go ship yes
hello nicolas for your question on
Burma good firstly I would like to
repeat you finally remind you that we have
we have we reacted
very very quickly to the current situation
in Burma with  a tweet from
president van der leyen of pr  president
michel and high representative
borel it is a it is a violation
which is very clear of the constitution
of the country and and the temptations of 2 the
attempt of the duduk or which was done
finally excuse me the attempt of the
military to de  overturning and not
accepting the will of the people of myanmar
and their attachment to democracy and
was deplored and we are we
condemned exact on this one there for your
question on what are the
sanctions we are not going to this  stage
I cannot answer at this stage and
we cannot speculate on the
possibility of taking a decision
on sanctions
it is a decision as you left which
must be taken unanimously at
council level that being said the
european union is looking at all
possible options that are in
regards to sanctions to respond in
a prompt manner to 7 to this situation
today
thank you very much we pass so we
remain on the theme ass  ez outside
another
four minutes before moving on
to other topics i would like to see if
we are finally there we it is a
wording without billing is
strong double event that deserves to be
seen
[Music]
we come back nour eddine foundation at
water but you can hear me yes hello
go ahead ah yes hello my question is about
the iranian nuclear file and
issues relating to the security of the
region
yes we understand that this has been said
several times in the european union
that the nuclear agreement
and the framework for discussion of
Iranian nuclear negotiations and that
the decision concerning the future
is up to the member states of the agreement and
the joint commission but there is a
question there are regional questions
which  concerns the regional ballot in
which pitel framework
the European Union could see
possible the discussion on the
Iranian ballistic missiles which poses
serious problems for the security of the
region as
well as obviously the  he crises and the
actions of the ranks in one
or another crisis in the region
these questions of ballistic missiles
regional crises do we need
a regional framework is it a
bilateral framework
how does the union  European that it is
the profusion have just seen how
the states of the region can
discuss these very serious problems and
is it possible to build
a kind of bridge between this
nuclear agreement is perhaps our forum for
the others  regional issues
thank you thank you reveals to us a very
fascinating subject but i will be very short the
priority now is to develop or
make every effort to ensure a
possible return of the united states to the nuclear court this
is the first priority
after the priority is  ensured the plan
full respect for the balls for the
nuclear treaty party of
all participants
the third priority if we can
pull this off we can discuss and we ca
n't use  ser that as a basis for having
a diallo that a plus a plus a
greater on security and stability in
all the regions which suffer
from it a lot of instability
so it is a continuation an order of
priorities like Thursday the priority
of humala  price the first priority is
to be on the return from the united states to
treat it and after the total respect of
all the participants for the
obligations
thank you very much pitot we will close
the external affairs chapter for
today and move on to  other topics
I told you that I unfortunately have to
end this
2010 appointment today at 1 p.m. and so I'll give
the floor to jean yes hello I'll
do if you can hear me
we're trying so day I cut g
cut the camera  to improve the flow
I had a question precisely to
call me it's over for the
spokesperson for josé borel but hey it's a
it doesn't matter he left it would be
good to get him back
I wanted him  ask if josep  borrell
had been associated with the preparation of the
text on the export of vaccines
since that poses a problem of
external relations since not only that
posed a problem with the British
as you know now are no longer
in the European union and therefore it  is a
problem of external relations and that also
posed a problem with all
the African countries in particular who feared that they
would no longer be able to have
access to vaccines if ever we took control
of the stocks of which I
would like to know if josep borrell has
been associated upstream in German I say
well and not only by
written procedure in the preparation of this text
I take this opportunity to say to make a
remark a little about this the system which
is put in place
it is nice this during the  first months
that is to say
conference but that means that we
can no longer have a direct relationship
with the spokespersons and pursue
questions besides the proof  that turn
off my authority microphone when
I could have explained that I had a
question to put to the
external relations spokesperson josée mme
borrel which poses a real problem of
democracy and freedom of the press in
France I signal you  there are again
face-to-face press conferences
with a limited number of journalists
with differences that are respected and
which precisely allows democracy
in the public space for debate to live
and not to be dependent on the  goodwill
of a spokesperson who can cut you off
at one time or another
when a common agreement so that
's a general remark second
thing then there on the other hand it
concerns you and frozen really
internal affairs we n  would not have asked the
question earlier I would like
you to really give me a
1st
minute-by-minute timeline of
the adoption of this text which was associated
with the preparation of the text which
precisely which person was  was
associated with the preparation of this text
which cabinet was associated with the
preparation of this text what
procedure was sent to adopt this text
and why no one saw the
Northern Irish problem I believe that in the
cabinet of Mrs von dach  elsewhere there
is someone called stephanie
rizo who i think was associated with
the deal with the british don who
should body and shooting and the sun
of allah so i really wanted to have
a line  time for me to understand
what happened because I ca
n't understand how such a
gross politically gross mistake
took the comice that's it thank
you thank you very much folks regarding
the first question on the top
representative is he was a partner
we already answered this
question earlier generally speaking
let's be clear we have a college which
therefore operates in a collegiate manner
based on service work and as
you know we don't have  We are not used to
doing it in this case either more
details and which official of the
commission
and which cabinets are associated in front
if this is obviously to say that there
is a cabinet which is which is the
leader in  in this case it was the cabinet
of the executive vice-president
mr dombrowski given that he is in
charge of trade and that this regulation
is the responsibility of the sending gentleman
which is his cabinet and of
course services  who depend on him
on these questions more
generally on the way in which this
decision was taken
I believe that we must take a step
back and during the holidays
the European Commission has been
in a situation of management since last March
an unprecedented crisis,
I believe we will all
agree on this, which has required us to adapt
our working methods and this implies
and in particular the fact that the
European Union has used and
continues to use  r on a very
regular basis emergency procedures
with regard to the adoption of texts in
order to deal with developments in
the end of the pandemic-related developments to
be responded to and the
procedure that was used for
the adoption  of this text is one decision
among almost 900 decisions that have
been taken last year and since the
beginning of the year in this area and
and in this way
and it is generally going
extremely well in this case in this case
In this case, what is clear is that between
the decision in principle which
was taken on Friday in the middle
of the afternoon and the final decision which
was taken on Friday very late
in the evening, we had  the opportunity
to take into account the situation that they
could be created by the
triggering of the safeguard clause
and we had discussions in
particular with the Irish Prime Minister
the afternoon the President of the
Committee as you know  is discussed
with the tee shot on these issues and
in the context of his political contacts
it was decided that of
course we had to find
another way to achieve our objective
and therefore we withdrew this article 16
to achieve the same objectives
by others by other means
so in the end the
final decision that was taken by the commission
and its I insist heavily on it is
a decision that did not include the
triggering of two mechanisms
safeguard of the safeguard clause the
famous article 16 of which you
spoke with regard to your general remark
I very much appreciate your comment
remember you jean you were extremely
virulent on twitter at the start of the
crisis
you blamed us for you  even having
kept the press room open
I remember it very well we are
trying to ensure that the
press room can remain open
as long as possible
we have  s given the evolution of the
pandemic was forced to close
it that said we very quickly
after put in place an interactive system
I am very happy to see that you are
using let me tell you that it is at
6.1 which  has been running for
more than nine months now and in
which journalists have the opportunity not
only to ask questions but
also the follow-up questions and you could
see before your question that others have
already had the opportunity to ask you  to ask the
questions am therefore very sincere it
allows us to have a dialogue with the
journalists which allows a follow-up which
allows quite in-depth interaction
and the proof is that I
often spend here with my colleagues
well over an hour  in the
press room in the press room
the last thing is that the
press room is one mechanism to dialogue
with us among many others
we are all in contact with you
every day through different means that
either by email to answer your
questions on the phone to chat
with you in off in the background where
you can always ask to
come and see us at berlaymont I have settled
mende and some of your colleagues who
come to see me where some of my
colleagues to discuss a subject so
I think that given the
circumstances
we are doing everything in our
power to precisely allow
the exercise of this freedom of the press
which is so dear to us and not only to
you I  now give the floor to
naomi who was the second to have raised her
hand on this question naomi durera from
swatch invests from dj flipper text
vistex sdn from scotland or and many
firms the prime view that you are
experiencing aulas week with the big
machine president and  from ska funk to empty
morning its empty chair response crosby
meeting accounting situation
text seals coes left vie lididi
india frame them sow score vein of all and
both stays easy game on friday vagaries
of a lifetime of his boots
yes the danish themes news with the
mud between life of these youngsters
main final clues of these youngsters
all modified text and find your way of
the rings winshuttle goal 36 in two
destinations vaccinate at expiration
[Music]
all three rooms of olivier besancenot
context with technicolor the
wind factor end of season daoust and to opt from
10am thing that i want you are working
hard for speed dating at three villages
in fine form of  refusal to go was taken
out did you get local pressure like
famous historical format africa country
animated 28 av
singh only the pope is infallible one
water one of the tubes correctly i hand over
to lawrence laurenzi twice
the swedish giant not virtual  fought
honey yeah I was expecting hello
hello michel hello listen to me I have
a question about the vaccine but
especially about communication has been in fact
for two days we s  we all ask the
same question do we have to speak German from
now on in this press room where to
be in their media profession the word
that I will be I salute in passing they
are very nice to have access
to Mrs von durden because we see
that  'every time things get
tough children from the n go quickly to
the German press never to the
French press Dutch Belgian
Spanish and so on
wouldn't it be simpler especially in these
times
when you  write her a few lines that
she could sign and when you
publish from aaron her tweets nine
european newspapers
even though she is the president of the
european commission she is not the
president of a commission or
germans of a lover that i  I am wrong
thank you thank you thousand is there you are not mistaken
the president indeed the
prison of the European commission and the
attraction at heart to dialogue
with all the European media and I
find I find  those comments a
wee bit narrow in that they
lose sight of all
of the president's media activities that you do
n't usually follow simply
because it's taking place in a
particular country that's not necessarily
on your radar  but let's just take them
left the president's media
since the beginning of the year the first
week after her return she was right
here in the press room to give a
press conference on precisely the
vaccine strategy the week after
before  her trip to lisbon the
president gave an interview to the group
and to all the
portuguese correspondents present here in brussels
precisely to prepare for her trip to
lisbon and explained that it was the
cooperation that bound allies that there
was going to be between the commission
european union and the portuguese presidency in
lisbon
she gave
a press conference with the
portuguese prime minister who speaks
thanks to the excellent  Moreover, the work
of the Portuguese presidency was also
open to correspondents from the
international press accredited in Brussels and
therefore you were able to ask your questions
both to the Portuguese Prime Minister and
the President the following week
following the view at the video conference
Heads of State and Government
Organized by the President of the
European Council She was again in the
press room
this time at the European Council
to dialogue with the press Finally,
as a reminder, just one example of
the mechanism at home  gave almost
20 different interviews to all the
audiovisual media of two countries who
had made a request to receive
to receive fall funds and
that he had obtained them to discuss
precisely this and does not doubt it for a
single second mia and there  you will
certainly very quickly have the opportunity
to hear the president express herself
in other media, even if he is
German-speaking or other, I pass  the floor
for pierre pierre antoine
sorry before passing the floor pierre
I forget something else again on
immigration day after president
biden the president gave three series
of television interviews on
English-speaking television on French-speaking television
went German-speaking television
that's how you can complete your list a little,
which seems a bit meager
to me, of the president's interventions in
the European and international media
cairo to you stone unfortunately we don't hear
it's for a
radio man don't  having the microphone cut off is
still a problem try to fix
it
so we don't hear anything if it's good
let's wait here yes my question is a
current one do we have a report
now of the increases in
delivery which was  planned by pfizer
for the return to the doses initially
planned for last week a
question for them from Etienne thank you
very much I leave the floor to stéphane
indeed even if  you cut
yesterday indeed we have some figures
concerning the delivery of the doses which
were made by file last week
so the week which has just passed
had 12 4 million doses were
delivered of which more or less 3.5
million  doses per balzac file and more or
less five hundred thousand doses per
model the delivery of this2 of these
doses corresponds to what was planned for
this week so only badly as
we announced a little while ago  we
had said that the coming week of the
costs of these castings would be 100% of the
deliveries
that indeed took place the company in addition
is committed to ensuring that
from February 15 all the
deliveries will be made and therefore we have
also  delivered you intend to continue
while i learned
so from February 15th normally
all they should have been delivered
every five weeks before would have
them will be delivered by thank you thank you
stéphane games has deflowered
costa james on di  t on dit folco between
the present in focus 10 offers
Friday
vico machine false transfer a
6th authorization expo tough vaccine 5
code windows phone by uk minister in 2.7
wemade specific watts
on water birds 6 elbow be seen from
the united  kingdom all the nutrients
context
yes yes yes yes yes you are afraid that we are
working in his webs to the notes
we want to top sellers out of
standing there was nothing nothing on
you guys which speed life of livry of
death from uk plant everything date date
concerns richard vaccinal contract with
harder towards strong assets at 38.15
also date contracting includes the year
in line in 2001 at the squat franck lida
kouassi n'da kyushu southwest or
astrazeneca
yes envy commission at the grillen of
context ford
which complaint  also aim like from hell
ride for reason of the company has to
ventas week the reception where are you going
we believe in the beginning of the stone
danic in chains interest that they
can pons
the  arcsecond watts 10 commission for
speed 8 km
nsue the practitioner and we have done
periods of the book in hand ball and the
body uses in his residences is
fort collins for false start of nick
and go away leaving in human lives or
six or  seven teams like so having been
she expresses the producers at 80 of the
wallet that we appt yes correct
and iacob situations
i'm exasperated five matches there's like
a god rue jean paul existing boots
what we are interested in and making sure
that we get  of books is that we had
contract that it takes a contract times ci
est number of trance date benson
specifically bad company has working to
do so
everything is here made of reasons sandwich
wii or erwin yes to an investigation
French aid
to this old  clery there this weekend
is 8 to 10 hinwil in terms of
vaccination company concerns wilkinson
date of this we have said he will stand
by death sale
we want to know what the drog exporting
countries in scree  n context the pee
wee man who dat and six notes and blocking
regulation and 1.10 per notification
gives authorization
an exporting dandy the clearance of the
system in place and exports 1,100
games benefits
nineteen the interim president good
technique the objectives  and sapwood three
to ensure that body paintings and fort
[Music]
to ten points of interest we want it come
back in date in all 5000
they have to get used to 10 hours
five cuvées match the Bernese
both suffered exposed in  the uk not
snags of a good for the star than
anders ngensu normal
ok five matches meaning this
book expo is back to back donald's
announces jets to life mechanism of
binational commissions a great
pretender is there will be kind  iacob
environmentalist friends this fall a
rigorous diet pill of 6min export off
weekend everyone to be taken on 100 dates in
america amassed only a
willy pass bills books that cause me
we have come back very strong  is
[Music]
diabolical to the star as a good
welcome
it reaches decision to stop at and
individual campanile is minimal and to
extreme the customers but we have had
cygnos marquette sales fatigue
nausea of ​​ailments that we move yes
fault if docile or  a banshee pts the
giannoli vaccine from the swico the rest
[Music]
says yes to the town hall
all the application of a
commission fund thank you soon as we move to
erik haegeman its pipes
as you surely know the water in metz a
strongly condemned the
export control introduced on friday and
said in geneva that it is a very bad
sign that it could feed
health nationalism it will remain and
there was also a statement if i
understood correctly from the lobbies or
international pharmaceutical manufacturers
organizations do you have any comment
on this are you breaking
with the who watts
correction thank you thank you very much
we are cooperating very closely
with the ms and this since the beginning of the
pandemic and if there is one institution
which has supported the work of the WHO and
which collaborates with it, in particular with
regard to the international response to the
pandemic, it is it  is indeed the
commission it is indeed the
European commission we have of course taken
note of these disputes its analyzes as
we do in
general and I would simply like to
recall here that once again the
President has said very clearly that it
it was absolutely not a question of blocking
deliveries of vaccines to countries that would
have or have contracts with
European vaccine producers but
simply to make sure that we know
what is happening is that
these companies also fulfill their
contractual obligations
in relation to the european union and the
member states so that the
european citizens that the vaccination plans
of the member states can be implemented
work
so here I believe that once again
it is a transparent and
balanced approach and which will contribute
to vaccination being able to progress both
in Europe and elsewhere derek yes hello
hello thank you one month I would like
a little more detailed explanations on
pfizer in the campaign tells them you will have
75 million more doses in
seconds in the second quarter
is what you have to understand that
these are doses what we expected for the
third and fourth quarters and that
they will finally arrive in the second
quarter  is that what you
have to understand and once we've said
that,
how many 12-hour queues will we have by the
end of June
how much a number quite simply a
number that doesn't cry  its 75 million
and second question which is linked
the president of the marianne stressed
to the zdf that despite
some good news it
would remain hard for february and march
is what in this context there europe
plans to turn or fall back
on vaccines towards orders for
Russian and Chinese vaccines as some are
starting to mention
thank you thank you I'll pass the floor to
stéphane
thank you many stops only a few
figures indeed so at the end of the month
of  September
no, first of all, what I must nevertheless
emphasize is that the plans,
the delivery plans
as provided for in the
contracts, are information that we
cannot give, which are covered
by confidentiality clauses, so
that  we cannot do what I
can however given as the information
is that at the end of September
we will have had the delivery
of more than 500 million doses
from biotechs had requested more than 500
million  of doses
if we include johnson johnson this
figure would rise to 600 million as
announced linked astrazeneca announced delivered
40 million doses of which an info
million dollars on the price side is there a
problem  me the problem is rather me
who excuses me ok so astrazeneca delivered
according to the latter announces 40 million
doses therefore 9 million
additional doses compared to what was
offered last week
if the important files with
regard to facing this  what I announced
a few minutes ago or underlined a
few minutes ago is that from
mid-February from February 15 fault
will be normalized I would say its deliveries
in the sense that from that moment on
all the deadlines that  the company had
incurred will normally be covered have
that from February 15
the delivery of 75 million or not in
75 million doses announced is due to
the skin to the development
of production capacities and will also take place
earlier and therefore which demonstrates that  we are
going in a good direction
regarding the delivery of the doses on
the question regarding the Russian
and Hungarian vaccines
you know that we have established our
vaccine strategy t  All the
selection criteria that companies must
meet in order to be able to manage
our vaccination portfolio, these
criteria concern, for example, the
necessary budgets but also the fact
that the companies must have a
production capacity in the European Union
precisely to allow one of the
deliveries  faster to European citizens
the company that thinks they can meet
this kind of criteria can obviously
always contact the
commissions and vice versa to see
what is possible with regard to the
Russian vaccine
you know that there are contacts between
the developer laboratory  of this vaccine
is the European Medicines Agency
thank you very much but louis no I was going to
add so as there is not at this
stage to my knowledge a request
for marketing authorization
for this vaccine
thank you thank you I  was passing the floor to david
yes thank you eric first of all i
'm telling you in shoes at the
press conference  from the beginning of January from
Mrs von der leyen
the president of the commission I
remind you of the context of this
press conference there was a controversy in
germany over the lack of doses and the
president made an announcement of a
new contract  with pfizer of 300
million and that was the purpose of the
press conference the day before
she had spoken to the defeated German media
of January 6 in America in
the United States so here we really have
the impression that Madam President is
talking  to the germans and my question
is does the commission mainly follow
the directives of germany in this
policy because last week
at the beginning it was a
transparency mechanism after it became a
mechanism under pressure from the
german government a mechanism
of export authorization and we met on
Friday with everything you know very
well
so here is what was the role
of Germany whose trial of the six
decision-making eyes of the c  ommission and in
particular from the office of Madam
President
second question if if I can that
compared to astrazeneca
how many doses will be able to deliver in the
second quarter if the figures we
had and the past figures are correct
so if we are going to recover throughout the
second quarter or not and is
the 40 million good for closing
chlorine closed by dont do it
astrazeneca
thank you to me to start with the second
mission there is no business
astrazeneca
there is a contractual relationship between
the european commission and a whole
series of vaccine producers in
europe in which the
european commission has invested 2.7 billion euros on behalf of the european union so
it seems to me perfectly legitimate
for the commission to insist on airs and
insist on obtaining the  deliveries
from the producers with which
it has signed a contract in good agreement
in dialogue and seeking
solutions and that is why there is  the
president said first fit or not it's
wrong and the pardon state for aids and
vaccine this because
the announcement that was made by
astrazeneca is going in the right direction
like others like other announcements that may
have been  be done and we will
of course continue with all
the vaccine producers to
ensure that we can maximize the
deliveries of vaccines in europe to
minimize the interruptions or
delays that could take place for
multiple reasons we know well
and we  have always said that there is
of course there is we are working on
a process that is complicated complex
including a loan from a
strictly industrial point of view and we are in
dialogue with companies
that's all in  regarding the
more precise calendar and the second
trimester I don't know if we can
provide you with more information here I'll pass
the floor to stéphane on that david and
I don't think I can give
more info  rations as you know the
planned deliveries for the
coming quarters are established within the
framework of the contracts concluded with the
company and this information can
only be shared with the agreement of the
companies so we cannot go into
the detail of these of its deliveries  there
obviously we're following the deliveries
as they happen that's why
i announced a few moments ago that
this last week we had
four million deliveries is
included basic and modern and the
longer term goals
thank you  thank you regarding your question on the
role of a particular member state, i
would simply like to remind you that of
course the commission on the one hand
works independently
with regard to the proposals
it formulates but on the other of
course that  'it works in good
agreement with all the member states in
order
in particular in this case to curb a
pandemic which affects us all and in
this context the  president is in
regular contact not just with the
representatives of the country she knows
best
but with many other countries of
the european union depending on the
circumstances and of course
first and foremost with the
portuguese presidency maintaining proposals
which are  don't they come out
of jupiter's thigh on thursday an italian
who certainly knows his
mythology well is much better than
me besides his latin mythology
However, it went very quickly and
as the project is deep of course
the dimensions of this project
can evolve
here we are going to take a
few more questions I'm sorry but
I will close at 1:30
am in her using the government
and yes naomi 1 from september
9:59 am and 10:28 am squash or in bolivia
from twitter
stafford i am denounced we have
received aus  if a contractor it takes to the
devil like a false date from
1 2 point
it's estate fund of choristers dialogue
continued world company including the
one woman show and new order to venture
established at 2.6 in duet with washington
photo stephane de sakutin by  nina
dies networks and brothers
stephen and 10.5 1200 f b forum
5 tommaso vaccine and make it live hard
to nathalie comments on which is or a
sale at 8 06 or in the name of a bomb of
christ church of the witch or death
on  features of cross where they go from
the help of his generals of these young people
making process as and once this sole or
just a little photo keystone speed bump
is what you received the
conclusions of the Belgian respondent in the
seneca factory and that they went
are they likely to
suggest that delivery delays
are indeed linked to production problems
stéphane thank you very much
the inspection of this factory has been
organized by the authorities  Belgian  s and
therefore you will have to address the
belgian authorities to the commission we have
no comments given on aspects
ctions which fall under the authority of
the member states thank you
lawrence reagan account there is a nice book
one ascquois xin wang new look of the
batteries  leaked contacted this low the
killing susanna to operate windows
astra zeneca that those of tweets machine
a magnificent experience sorting capacity
new look so reading and 10 mine to be
admitted was hostile
wait to follow the christ arise this
fusion 4 expecting anna faris and quickly
and light where both feature
female figures sims status and
talking about nothing figure talking a few
weeks ago quiet at 5 came back to
bonn with a click the offers to
susanna hairstyles yes from the front a tweet to go there
and stafford and that  proves to me in
privacy s figure date a release the
three astrazeneca tags definitely not
be among which
we expect to receive continues to
cling natas de photos st  éphane
proust production twitter.com expertise
yes and feed everything she is and this
despicable maxim's production pilot
with one love queen trades everything griselda
griselda thiès the palabra
thinking it doesn't work and there I'm
sorry so we're going to go for the
last question with regret from the five
classes 9 legal hours all life of these
young people it's for a clasico is so fine
of these young people which excuses in our eyes
absolutely no 15 axes league all i want
is hoping season commission at which his
winery matches arrive  all in half
debriefings which